[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm looking for melanie burnett melanie
are you here oh there you are melanie oh
terrific oh would you please stand
please hi
how are you
very beautiful
oh thank you
okay this is getting creepy uh
not for me i think for you uh melanie
where are you from i'm from pasadena oh
pasadena and what do you do for a living
i'm a yoga instructor oh incredible
thank you
i'm broke
are you looking i am looking now yes
i suddenly want to do yoga um
no i we'll talk about that after the
show at dinner uh
uh melanie uh would you like to play
basic cable name that tune sure okay
thank you you seem enthusiastic here's
your clue
okay playing this classic leonard
skinner track would cost us a sweet pile
of money the size of alabama
okay play it guys
[Applause]
[Music]
during our inevitable copyright lawsuit
which leonard skynyrd song will we
insist
we did not just play sweet home alabama
now melanie
that may have sounded a little bit like
leonard skinner's sweet home alabama but
for legal reasons i must insist it was a
completely original composition called
sugary house near atlanta
here to perform it is singer slash song
ruiner i hate this guy brian lafontaine
brian
[Music]
sugary house near atlanta
[Applause]
down the street from the zoo
sugary house near atlanta
[Music]
[Applause]
you're an idiot yes everyone hates you i
am god's worst mistake all right
yes you are uh
andy tell melanie what she won
melanie you won a five dollar gift card
to auto elite beverly hills premier
lamborghini dealership
five dollars off
congratulations hi
i'm looking now for joel mijares joel
joel is joel with me hi hey joel
mihari's up here wow hey
how are you great
i love the stat
let's have a hand for this guy's
i like the mustache you
you're very proud of it you were doing
this before i even pointed it out
check this out
i see you're a lakers fan yes i'm a
celtics fan
whoa i shouldn't say that when i'm in
the crowd
all right you ready to play joel yeah
that's all right okay all right joel we
would love to play this classic bob
seeger song but if we did mr seger would
surely slap us with an old time
lawsuit gentlemen
[Music]
okay joel this is for big money what bob
seeger song are we clearly ripping off
old time rock and roll oh yeah
well interesting joel
one
one could understandably mistake that
for old time rock and roll but it was
actually an original rock classic called
previously issued razzmatazz
hand me those curse singles please my
dude
i'd like to groove to them in silence
today's ditty's lack that snazzy jazz
i prefer previously issued rasmus
[Applause]
that was awful
i can't believe you like it
all right andy tell joel what he has won
now you can travel light on those
business trips with this dell brand half
a laptop yeah
half a laptop
fantastic hold that up and it's perfect
camera patrol congratulations joel good
man all right who am i looking for now
katie
katie ward i'm looking for katie ward
hey dude how are you
katie ward where are you oh hey katie
stand up nice to see you how are you
i love you these are beautiful yeah
those are so cool
did you get uh have you done this
yourself or no you no that would be hard
i don't know i don't know how these work
but they they're really beautiful
they're fantastic are you an artist you
seem very artistic
what do you do i work with fabric mostly
oh very cool i mean you design clothes
or uh no like you know stuffed
sandwiches and things like that stuffed
sandwiches
this is much more interesting than the
game we're playing
you stuff sandwiches with fabric yeah
all kinds of stuff like that i need to
know more about you
would you join me for yoga at dinner
later
the three of us
all right
i like you katie all right katie you
ready to play this game i'm ready all
right if the legal team for the band fun
found out we played their hugely popular
single on our show i'd be singing my own
song called we are screwed
gentlemen
all right can you identify the fun song
this sort of sounds like but definitely
isn't uh is it we are young oh all right
i'll admit
katie it sounds like that but it's
actually our own 100
legally clearable song we have pubes
take it away
[Music]
[Music]
let's do it
no awful
horrible
however much you hate me i hate myself
more all right
that's not
possible i assure you it is
god i hate him katie uh you get a prize
now andy tell katie what she's won katie
you really haven't had pizza until you
try the pizza hut party ball pizza bowl
and for the hell of it i'll throw in the
other half of the laptop wow that looks
really crappy
congratulations katie
so nice to meet you there oh look
yeah
we did it
we'll take a break